so we have in the past spent many
cumulative hours looking at uh tick tock
videos together time
not really time well spent time wasted
pitifully and terribly wasted the point
is we're going to watch uh some more
tick tock videos today only this time
we're plunging all the way down into the
depths the bowels of tik-tok to discover
and analyze the saddest most disturbed
most deranged community of all those are
the male feminists on tick tock it won't
surprise you to learn that there are
many male feminists on tick tock and
they have made all kinds of videos
things are about to get very depressing
in a hurry so let's uh let's start here
if you think that
being a feminist makes you any less of a
man
you're admitting that your version of
masculinity
requires the oppression of women
[Music]
uh what
no it requires the oppression of you
you're someone who should be oppressed
for the good of mankind as a male
feminist or maybe simply ejected off of
the earth and uh and into the void of
space i don't know i'm fine with that
compromise that works too notice by the
way this guy's username is a turtleneck
emo so he's literally combined the two
worst things humanity ever invented and
put them into one username anyway does
being a feminist make you less of a man
uh of course it does because men are
meant to be strong they're meant to be
leaders and by calling yourself a
feminist you're proudly showing off not
only your intellectual moral weakness
but your collectivist mentality as well
so yes that makes you that makes you
certainly less of a man
um
and we will see more examples of that as
we continue along okay let's look at the
next one sorry tough guys it's part two
of a day in the life of the stay-at-home
husband when i say check your misogyny
at the door i mean it
it's the weekend so you know i gotta let
my queen sleep in so i make her some
pancakes she likes them with chocolate
chippies in them after i flip the script
on these gender norms she wakes up to a
hot plate of pancakes on sundays we
strip the sheets and then i load the
dishwasher next i borrow my wife's
credit card and i go get some groceries
i check those eggs check out make my way
home and put the groceries away the
fridge organized with all her favorite
drinks and snacks and then i take the
trash out to where the men go don't
strain yourself queen you work too hard
you know the drill follow that in the
patriarchy speaking of being less of a
man um
stay-at-home husband not even a
stay-at-home dad
which is which is already a dubious
proposition in and of itself
this dude's not taking care of kids
this is called being a useless deadbeat
that's what that's called
[Music]
you know what i really call it i call it
your wife is cheating on you
that's what i would call it or she will
anyway if she's not already and i mean
that sincerely and seriously because
even if she kind of enjoys the frills of
having her husband play house made and
she likes the chocolate chippies and
tolerates the fact that you call them
chippies
the fact is that she doesn't respect you
and marriages cannot survive intact
absolutely cannot cannot survive if the
wife does not respect the husband
when you're not leading and you're not
providing and you're not being useful
and you're not fulfilling your role as a
man the role that has animated men and
given us purpose since time immemorial
to fight for our families and for our
women and to provide for them you know
to go back back in the old days you were
going out and you were hunting and you
were bringing back the game that you
killed and now it's a different kind of
hunting you go out into the work world
and you and you earn a living and you
bring back that paycheck and you take
care of your family that's what women
respect
now there are feminists of course who
who think that they shouldn't respect
men at all really but and they
especially shouldn't respect men on that
basis so they try to
they try to talk themselves out of that
but they can't
because it's it's an innate biological
impulse
so if you're not doing that she won't
respect you and uh and that's when the
marriage will fall apart but otherwise
great great plan all right let's
continue uh doc i broke my arm you got
to help me oh my god get this man to
surgery
hi um i have broken my arm oh my god
[Music]
can't help but feel
it wouldn't have broken if you've lost
weight you see how the misogyny
basically doesn't exist anymore in our
country
because if it did
you wouldn't have to invent totally
fictional examples of it like this if
you come into to the doctor with a
broken arm as a woman they're gonna
they're gonna elect you for for being
overweight uh besides obesity can cause
broken arms
what if you busted through a trampoline
or something
you know so that can happen but this is
invented misogyny which shows you that
uh that
basically doesn't exist anymore the the
demand just like with hate crimes and
that's how you get justice millet the
demand for misogyny is um
is greater than the supply here's some
trivia for you what is both the
best-selling book of all time and the
best-selling book each and every year uh
my book johnny the walrus no i'm just
kidding it's actually the bible and um i
think we all have to recognize the
wisdom of the bible and that has stood
the test of time we also should know
that it's well worth everyone's time to
read this jewel of a book but having
time to read anything these days was
proving more and more difficult that's
why the audio bible app dwell exists
that's why i use it every day the five
star app makes it so easy to get into
the bible by providing a world-class
listening experience that you have to
hear and see to believe you just have to
try it for yourself go to dwell app dot
io slash walsh to try dwell for free for
seven days this audio bible app includes
12 different narrators each with a
unique accent which always keeps your
listening experience fresh
it has all of your favorite bible
versions the niv the nk jv the esv the
nrsv the kgb and many more
you can weave in beautiful instrumental
music in the background if you like it
even has a really handy read-along
feature that combines both sight and
sound for increased comprehension we all
know we need to get more into the bible
you need to spend more time in it each
day it can be hard sometimes to find the
time for it dwell makes it a lot easier
to find that time and it makes the
listening experience a pleasure so go
now to dwell app dot io slash walsh and
try dwell free for seven days and begin
your journey of rediscovering wisdom and
truth found in this timeless book
hey ladies so is there any statistical
proof you can give me that women have it
worse than men and
women are 47 more likely to suffer
severe injuries in car crashes because
safety features are designed for men
33 000 girls become child brides every
day
women in rural parts of africa spend 40
billion hours a year collecting water
at the rate we're going it will take 108
years to close the gender pay gap
as of right now only six countries give
women equal legal work rights as men
and for every female film character
there are 2.24 more men just your
friendly neighborhood feminist trying to
knock down toxic masculinity doing my
best
doing my best
oh my god
so okay so so we have a we have a whole
bunch of claims here safety features on
vehicles are designed for men he says i
don't know what he's talking about with
that
even if that was true by the way
wouldn't that be kind of interesting
like because because people like him
would i'm sure also tell me that men can
actually be women and they can compete
against women in sports and that uh in
that context there's no inherent
difference between males and and female
bodies and we're all the same
so so which is it if you're saying that
the male female body are different and
the cars are more designed with the male
body in mind that seem to suggest that
there is a difference between the bodies
so you kind of have to decide also for
as for child brides
um that is a real problem in the world
take that up with fundamentalist islam
where by the way young boys don't fare
too well either
women in rural rural africa collect lots
of water
okay
what are the men doing how many hours do
they spend hunting or farming or
performing other manual tasks it's rural
africa
how do you think it works there
[Applause]
you think the men are just kicking back
and relaxing
so being being in a third world country
is is great if you're a man they they're
enjoying it
it'll take 108 years to close the gender
pay gap well that's not true because the
gender pay gap is a myth
and there are more male film characters
again assuming that's true you know and
you've got to take all this with a grain
of salt
so so
what you're trying to prove
that it's harder to be a woman in
america
in the year 2021
and
one of the pieces of evidence that you
choose is that allegedly there are more
male film characters that's that makes a
woman's life harder
is that when they turn on tv to watch a
movie they see more male characters what
does that cause like physical pain
emotional anguish
well i will see all of those statistics
dubious as they may be and i will raise
you this the majority of homeless people
are men the majority of prison inmates
are men the majority of homicide victims
are men the majority of violent crime
victims are men the majority of high
school dropouts are men are men
males are more likely to die by suicide
more likely to be injured on the job
more likely to have the kinds of
physically demanding jobs where you get
injured in the first place
so there's all that there's the suicide
and homelessness and drug addiction and
unemployment dropping out of school all
the you know in prison
and that's kind of tough but on the
other hand at least we have more
film characters that are the same sex as
us
okay
[Music]
okay i don't think that was a man on
second thought i'm not i can't be too
sure as far as the idea that men
shouldn't chime in on abortion i i mean
just shut up shut up [ __ ] up
okay if we let's run through the
problems with that claim one more time
number one you can't do that anymore as
we just talked about the car thing
you believe that that there are no
differences between the male and female
bodies
that it's fluid you believe that you
could be have a male body and still be a
woman and that you're just as much a
woman as any other one so you can't play
this card anymore that's been taken from
you it's gone it's not in the deck
anymore you can't play it also men
decided roe v wade so if we're gonna get
rid of male opinions on abortion that
means we're getting rid of roe v wade
men also are 50 of the ingredients
needed to create an unborn child which
you would all which you would also think
would give us a stake in the question
i'm gonna have an aneurysm if we watch
too many more of these
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm honestly not sure if that was a man
either i'm not saying that to be funny i
really don't know
um and i believe in the biological
differences between the sexes but i'll
admit that sometimes male feminists can
test my faith in that idea and uh and
yet again we get the the men shouldn't
have an opinion on ex-subject thing you
know so so what we see is that to be a
feminist man is to be a neutered man a
controlled man a man shorn of
personality and identity a baby-faced
ball-less simpering eunuch this after
all is the the objective of feminism to
destroy men destroy manhood male
feminists are the utopian ideal of
manhood according to feminism because
they are manhood without manhood they
are the absence of man or they're they
are a void they meant a monstrosity a
disgrace
an embarrassment to their fathers and
their ancestors
other than that you know male feminism
is great
if you are not a male feminist make sure
that you like and subscribe in fact
let me let me amend that if you are a
male feminist there's even more reason
you need you need more of these kinds of
videos so make sure you hit that like
button and subscribe